oh
blackout
[Music]
oh sorry buddy everything's okay
uh excuse me we did not order a
poltergeist
um if this is the pizza guy this is
really unprofessional
[Music]
eggman
hello
hedgehog
did you miss me
i don't know how you got back but you
made a big mistake coming here oh
contrermo
the mistake was thinking you'd won
but that was just a prelude an hors
d'oeuvre and a party and a moose bush i
get it
i don't think you do
but you're about to and so will that
idiot sheriff and his wife
and your little dog too
[Music]
beautiful
oh what
who are you
where
are my manners
sonic
meet knuckles
my new bffae
bestest friend forever and ever
look robotnik i don't care who you
brought to help you you're never going
to get my power do i look like i need
your power
so nice when diabolical evil lives up to
the hype
where is it oh you want it
here it comes i was expecting more of
you
you're unskilled
untrained
and
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
oh
it is my destiny to do what my ancestors
could not to restore the ultimate power
to the home of my people
uh ultimate power i don't know what
you're talking about
you've got the wrong guy
ultimate power
now you speaking my language don't play
dumb with me apprentice of long flaw
you knew claw long clawed her people
were the sworn enemy of my tribe the
echidna we fought and died at their
hands and now you will die in my
[Music]
come on get in i'm on your side i'm
sorry who are you
you know what it doesn't matter
is
make sure to get your shots egg man
[Music]
wow okay let me just say it is an honor
to finally meet you sonic is it okay if
i call you sonic everyone calls me tails
you're probably wondering why let me
guess
because of the extra tail that's right i
should have known you'd get that cool
also what is going on robotnik's back
and who is clifford the big red rage
monster that's knuckles the last of the
echidnas and the most dangerous warrior
in the galaxy he's obsessed with finding
the master emerald are you serious the
master emerald that's just a bedtime
story well he believes it's real and he
must think you're the key to finding it
red light red light give me the wheel
hey where are you move your foot
[Applause]
oh i think we lost him
we did not lose him we definitely did
not lose him
[Applause]
i got an idea do you trust me of course
not i literally just met you
what are you doing
[Music]
[Music]
we're flying
uh did your butt just turn into a
helicopter
a quadcopter oh only sonic the hedgehog
could come up with something like that
foxy moves
want something done right
you have to hire someone you can push
around